what the heck is the Dow for many people
the Dow is one of those terms that when
you hear it on TV or read it in an
article your eyes glaze over and your
mind wanders to something more relevant
to your life like whether you could fit
12 marshmallows in your mouth at once
but how do you know you don't need to
know what the Dow is when you don't know
what the Dow is in the late 19th century
a newspaper editor named Charles Dow and
a statistician named Edward Jones why
don't you create a simple tool for
measuring how the US economy was doing
day to day since most of the economy was
industrial at the time they decided to
combine the stock prices of the 12
biggest industrial companies into one
statistic the Dow Jones Industrial
Average those 12 companies were American
cotton oil company American Sugar
Company
tobacco company Chicago gas company
distilling in cattle feeding Company
Laclede gas company national lead
company North American company Tennessee
coal iron and railroad company us
leather company United States Rubber
Company and the only one still on the
Dow today
General Electric today 30 companies make
up the Dow and their share prices are
used as an index or a benchmark not just
for how the stock market is performing
in general but also how specific
companies are performing compared to the
market so for instance if you owned a
blue-chip stock that's holding steady
while the Dow is going down you can say
that your stock is outperforming the
market but we admit it there's almost
4,000 companies being traded on the US
stock market how can just 30 provide a
reliable snapshot no matter how big they
are that's a valid question
some people think the Dow's importance
has been blown way out of proportion
after all these 30 companies can be
doing well while most Americans are
hurting like in the case of massive
layoffs and as you've probably noticed
they do a lot of business overseas so
their share prices don't necessarily
reflect the strength of the American
economy so why do you Cable News hosts
still endlessly refer to it as if it's
the end-all be-all of mark and
measurement Dow Dow Dow Dow well the
stock market's funny thing since its
gains and losses are driven largely by
whether people are deciding to buy or
sell
actually happening in the economy is
less important than what people think is
happening an individual stockbroker is
trying to guess but all the other
stockbrokers are going to do but all the
other stockbrokers are thinking the
exact same thing each investor needs to
watch the Dow simply because he or she
knows that every other investor is
watching the Dow it's the starting point
of an endless guessing game that often
leads to over-reactive bubbles and
plunges Adam Davidson of the New York
Times called the doubt and anxiety
amplification device so do you need to
worry about the Dow should you track it
like a hawk updating your 401k with
every news story or should you just
ignore it
neither knowing what the Dow is and
isn't will help protect you from the
hysteria that can dominate the news in
times of worry but you should know that
it's just one of the many indicators of
how things are going in the US economy
like GDP employment numbers in Treasury
interest rates maybe we should take a
cue from the man it's named for Charles
Dow was observed to rarely look at the
index himself and the executive director
of Dow Jones Indexes John presto
recommended that the average investor
should only look at the index around
once a quarter or once a month at the
very most so the next time you hear
someone on cable news yelling about the
Dow now that you know what it is you
could probably go back to what you were
doing and that's our two cents
you
[Music]